-Frédérique Pons,
vous avez été l'avocate
de Guy Georges,
celui que la presse a surnommé
le tueur de l'est parisien,
les Français découvrent avec lui
la figure du serial killer,
une psychose collective
s'empare du pays,
c'est dire si l'émotion est grande
quand vous héritez du dossier.
D'ailleurs,
comment en héritez-vous ?
-J'allais dire
de manière familiale
car son avocat, à l'époque,
il a changé d'avocat
plusieurs fois, mais le dernier,
là depuis longtemps,
c'était Alex Ursulet,
mon ancien mari, voilà,
et quelque temps avant,
y a eu des personnes qui devaient
le défendre, avec lui,
qui finalement avaient renoncé,
donc il m'avait dit :
il faut absolument
que tu viennes avec moi.
Et deux mois avant les assises,
très peu de temps avant,
ça s'est fait.
-Est-ce qu'il est venu aussi
chercher la femme
derrière la robe ?
Ce n'est pas anodin,
d'être une femme,
dans ce genre d'affaire.
-Oui, oui.
Oui, parce qu'on a travaillé,
on avait travaillé souvent ensemble
et ça m'est arrivé
effectivement souvent,
sur des affaires de viol,
d'agression sexuelle,
qu'on soit deux,
un binôme mixte, euh,
parce que...
Je pense que,
surtout quand on veut plaider
un acquittement,
qu'on veut contester la culpabilité,
c'est plus facile,
je pense, pour une femme
de s'adresser d'abord
à une autre femme
et d'entrer dans des détails,
dirons-nous,
techniques sans être
intrusive ou...
vulgaire, ou grossière,
ou voilà.
-Pourquoi avoir accepté
cette affaire et surtout
comment l'assume-t-on
auprès de ses proches ?
Vous avez dû beaucoup
entendre cette phrase :
comment peux-tu défendre
un homme pareil ?
-Et même : pourquoi peux-tu
défendre un monstre ?
Donc la première chose,
c'est de passer
le cap du monstre,
d'essayer de rappeler
que c'est un homme.
-Pour vous,
les monstres n'existent
que dans les contes,
n'est-ce pas ?
-Oui, ce serait tellement facile,
si le monstre existait,
ce serait...
On réglerait tellement de problèmes,
comme ça,
mais ce qui est
justement vertigineux,
c'est de se dire
que la limite entre l'homme
j'allais dire lambda
et l'homme qui va passer à l'acte,
qui va basculer
dans une criminalité,
elle est...
Souvent, on voit
que c'est très fragile,
enfin,
donc c'est vertigineux,
donc c'est inquiétant
et donc on parle du monstre.
On défend des hommes
mais, bien évidemment,
on ne défend pas les faits.
-A l'époque,
vous étiez convaincue
de son innocence.
Au moment
où vous le rencontrez,
vous ne lui posez même pas
la question de savoir
s'il est coupable ou non.
-Disons que,
au moment de le rencontrer,
j'ai pas eu l'occasion
de parler avec lui longtemps
mais la rencontre était essentielle
pour accepter de le défendre,
savoir ce qu'il dégageait,
qui il était,
quelle était sa position
car, au cours du dossier,
il avait varié.
Et, dans le dossier Guy Georges,
pendant longtemps,
y a eu plusieurs juges
d'instruction,
on a cherché plusieurs pistes,
c'était pas évident que ce soit lui.
Ce qui a fait l'évidence,
c'était l'ADN or, il se trouve que
l'expertise ADN, en gros,
n'était ni faite ni à faire.
Il y avait eu à un moment donné
une faute de frappe,
donc ce n'était pas Guy Georges,
deux ans après, c'était lui.
Enfin bon,
c'est pas sérieux.
Ce dont je voulais être certaine,
c'est qu'il accepte
un autre prélèvement ADN
et qu'on refasse une expertise ADN
si la cour l'ordonnait, voilà.
-Et il était d'accord.
-Oui.
-Vous ne croyez pas aux monstres,
Frédérique Pons,
mais faut-il,
au fond, du courage
ou une foi incorrigible
en l'être humain
pour voir de la lumière là où chacun
justement voit un monstre ?
-Oui, je pense qu'il faut avoir
la foi en l'être humain,
croire que, en tout homme,
on peut trouver quelque chose, oui,
je crois qu'il faut aimer,
justement,
cette recherche,
aimer comprendre.
Et je pense que,
être avocat, c'est ça.
Parce que,
on dit toujours que,
pour juger, il faut comprendre
et, le magistrat,
je pense qu'il a besoin
de l'avocat comme interprète,
pour lui donner les clefs,
parce qu'une audience, c'est rapide.
Nous, on côtoie des individus
pendant plusieurs années,
on capte des clefs,
on capte...
Donc ça aide à la défense.
-Jean-Yves Moyart
feu Jean-Yves Moyart,
maître Mô,
disait que l'avocat est le frère
en humanité de l'accusé.
-Oui, formidable phrase,
effectivement.
Oui, y a un lien très fort
et il faut avoir cette conviction
qu'on est là pour les aider,
qu'on est là pour comprendre,
qu'on est là...
voilà,
c'est pas juste du droit, hein,
on fait pas un métier...
Bien sûr, y a un travail
très chirurgical
d'analyse des pièces,
d'analyse des indices
et de discussion,
mais y a énormément
d'humanité, d'émotion...
C'est ça, je pense,
qui nous permet de défendre,
on est là pour porter leur voix.
-Vous exercez un métier
où l'on assimile souvent
l'avocat à son client.
L'affaire Guy Georges
vous a-t-elle valu
des agressions physiques,
verbales ?
Vous avez dû concentrer beaucoup
de haine à travers lui.
-Forcément parce que certaines
personnes ne comprennent pas
le rôle de l'avocat
et donc identifient...
Et puis, comme Guy Georges,
on sait pas forcément où il est,
donc c'est beaucoup plus facile
de s'adresser à son avocat
et de lui envoyer
des lettres de menaces, oui.
-Lettres émanant de qui ?
D'anonymes ?
De parties civiles ?
-Oui, c'est, c'est...
Non, jamais les parties civiles,
non, non, non.
Mais bon, il m'est arrivé
de plaider dans une affaire
de terrorisme un peu sensible,
l'affaire Chapour Bakhtiar,
donc très politique,
on est sortis du palais vraiment
un peu poursuivis et coursés
par les partisans de l'autre camp.
-Y a-t-il une fierté, justement,
à aller dans ces affaires
à contre-courant
de la pensée dominante ?
-Faut aimer le challenge, oui,
faut aimer le combat, euh,
et puis, quand ça se passe bien,
Chapour Bakhtiar,
ça s'est fini par un acquittement,
oui, on est très contents
et puis on a le sentiment, voilà,
de participer à l'oeuvre de justice.
Moi, ça fait plus de 40 ans
que je fais ce métier,
j'y crois encore, je veux dire,
je crois encore au pouvoir
des magistrats quand tout
accuse quelqu'un,
quand quelqu'un a été accusé
pendant plusieurs années,
je crois encore au pouvoir
des magistrats et au pouvoir
de conviction qu'on peut dégager
pour leur faire dire halte,
la machine judiciaire doit
s'arrêter, à un moment donné,
il faut arrêter, il faut libérer.
Quelquefois, ça arrive.
-Alors revenons
à l'affaire Guy Georges.
Quel souvenir gardez-vous
de votre première rencontre
au parloir de la Santé ?
Par quoi avez-vous été traversée
lors de cette première rencontre ?
-Ce que je voulais,
avant tout,
c'était de rencontrer,
de rencontrer l'homme,
de rencontrer,
pas de parler du dossier
mais de le rencontrer,
voir ce qu'il dégageait
parce que...
Dans la vie, il y a des individus,
vous les croisez dans une pièce,
immédiatement vous savez
que vous n'avez aucun atome crochu
et leur dire bonjour
va être difficile.
Si j'avais eu une telle réaction
avec Guy Georges,
je n'aurais pas pu le défendre,
ça aurait été trop hypocrite.
J'avais besoin de le rencontrer,
qu'il me parle de sa vie carcérale,
comment ça se passait.
Finalement, j'ai rencontré
un homme tout à fait ordinaire,
plutôt sympathique, euh...
Voilà, c'est tout le problème
de ces personnalités clivées,
comme l'ont dit
les psychiatres.
Un jour, il est là,
ordinaire...
-Mais avez-vous éprouvé
de l'empathie pour l'homme ?
-Oui, dans la mesure où...
-D'ailleurs faut-il avoir
de l'empathie pour bien défendre ?
-Je crois.
Je pense qu'on ne peut pas
être indifférent,
il faut avoir envie de comprendre,
avoir envie de quelque chose, oui.
-Votre consoeur Olivia Ronen,
qui a défendu Abdeslam,
dit qu'elle n'a pas
d'exigence de vérité
mais de sincérité.
La nuance est importante ?
-Ils ont le droit de mentir.
Ils ont le droit de mentir,
ils ont le droit de mentir,
même à leur avocat.
Après, le problème est
une question d'efficacité,
c'est-à-dire que si la personne
vous dit qu'elle n'est pas coupable
et si elle veut obtenir
ce résultat-là,
nous, on est tenus de lui expliquer
tout ce qu'il y a dans le dossier
avec les présomptions, indices,
éléments à charge, de les discuter,
on est tenus de le challenger,
de faire l'avocat du diable.
Après, si la personne vous ment
de manière effrontée, etc.,
Bon, c'est son choix,
mais on lui aura dit aussi :
là, ça va être difficile,
quand même, de...
-Pour nombre d'avocats,
la défense prime sur la vérité.
L'avocat n'a pas vocation
à faire avouer son client
pas plus qu'il n'est soumis
au devoir de vérité.
-Non, et puis,
de toute façon, après,
il va y avoir
la vérité judiciaire,
mais quand on aborde un dossier,
ce que l'on pense réellement
de la culpabilité ou pas, moi,
je considère que c'est totalement
indifférent.
La seule chose qu'on doit,
à notre client,
c'est d'avoir extrêmement bien
étudié le dossier,
de lui en donner
une connaissance parfaite,
de l'aider à comprendre
et, à partir de là, de voir
ce qui est faisable et, en plus,
ce qu'on se sent capable
de défendre, aussi.
Je peux comprendre que peut-être
certains ne pourraient pas défendre
certains points de vue.
-Vous, vous étiez convaincue
de son innocence
et vous avez plaidé le droit,
vous avez appuyé sur toutes
les failles de l'enquête,
portrait-robot peu ressemblant,
absence de pied égyptien,
erreur dans la comparaison
des ADN.
-Oui, jusqu'à la veille
ou l'avant-veille
de l'arrestation de Guy Georges,
y a des personnes,
les soupçons allaient
sur d'autres personnes.
Donc j'étais surtout convaincue
qu'il y avait matière à discuter.
Y avait des éléments à plaider,
à expliquer, voilà.
Etant précisé que, le principal,
c'était évidemment l'ADN.
-Etiez-vous convaincue, encore,
de son innocence ?
Fondamentalement ?
-Vous savez, je...
Je sais pas si j'étais...
Est-ce que j'aurais
mis ma main au feu ?
Mis ma main à couper ? Non.
J'étais convaincue que, oui,
y avait du travail à faire,
j'étais convaincue
qu'on pouvait défendre,
détruire un dossier, mais voilà,
mais encore une fois
parce que ma conviction profonde
n'est pas intéressante
et n'intervient pas
dans ma capacité à défendre.
-Rétrospectivement,
et si c'était à refaire,
est-ce que vous soutiendriez
cette ligne de défense
très offensive,
pour ne pas dire agressive, au fond,
digne d'un Vergès ?
-Oh non, pas digne d'un Vergès !
Vergès avait ce... ce...
ce talent de...
Il avait cette histoire, d'abord,
qui était derrière lui,
qui lui permettait de revendiquer,
et il avait un combat politique
qui le conduisait à remettre
en cause y compris le droit
des magistrats de juger.
Nous, on était pas là-dedans.
-Mais la stratégie
et la ligne de défense
étaient perçues
comme blasphématoires
par les victimes.
-Oui,
mais parce qu'il n'a pas été
compris à quel point
l'erreur sur l'ADN
était importante.
En 1995, on arrête Guy Georges,
il est d'accord,
on lui fait un prélèvement ADN,
on analyse son ADN,
on le décrypte,
c'est une série de chiffres,
cette série de chiffres est comparée
à ce qui était dans le dossier,
qui était l'ADN du killer,
et ça n'est pas la même chose.
Deux ans après,
on vient nous dire qu'il y a
une erreur de frappe,
et là, ça matche.
Comment peut-on dans un système
démocratique aussi développé
que celui de la France
admettre qu'on puisse envoyer
quelqu'un en prison
sur la base de rapports d'expertise
aussi contradictoires ?
Qu'est-ce qui me prouve que,
en 1995,
y a eu une erreur de frappe ?
Soit on me donne
ce qu'on appelle les gels,
soit on me donne tout,
mais on ne vient pas, doctement,
avec de beaux écrans Power Point,
devant une cour d'assises,
m'expliquer que tout va bien.
Ca n'est pas possible.
Donc ça, ça n'a pas été compris,
je crois,
même par les parties civiles,
et puis, d'ailleurs,
il faut quand même
voir que,
en 95, si Guy Georges,
si l'ADN avait été
correctement décrypté,
Guy Georges était arrêté...
-Beaucoup plus tôt.
-Il était maintenu en détention,
ça évitait quand même deux meurtres.
Je veux dire,
la responsabilité de l'Etat...
Bon, c'était plus simple
de considérer qu'il y avait pas
de responsabilité du tout
et donc, voilà.
Donc si c'était à refaire,
je referais exactement la même chose
parce que c'est très bien,
la science, c'est très bien,
les experts,
mais les experts
sont faillibles.
-Lors du procès,
Guy Georges commence
par clamer son innocence
mais, au cinquième jour,
le procès bascule,
maître Solange Doumic,
avocate de partie civile,
lui demande s'il est droitier
ou gaucher
et là, brusquement,
il mime un coup qui part,
un geste comme un aveu,
il se piège, la consternation,
qu'est-ce que vous ressentez
à ce moment-là ?
-Euh, vous savez, le ciel
qui tombe sur la tête, voilà.
Voilà, ou dans les dessins animés,
tout qui s'effondre, là,
tll-tll-tlla.
Voilà, le mur de verre qui tombe.
-Encore maintenant,
on sent que c'est un moment...
-Ah oui, Solange Doumic
a été absolument formidable,
ce moment d'assises,
je pense,
restera dans l'histoire
des cours d'assises,
ça, pour le coup,
c'était un moment de vérité,
et ce qu'il y a de formidable,
c'est que c'était
un moment de vérité
quasiment sans parole
car il a suffi que Guy Georges
fasse ce geste,
la mitraille du regard
et là, tout était dit.
-Oui, un moment d'assises
comme il s'en produit
rarement,
dans cette salle bondée,
une petite voix s'élève,
après ses aveux,
pour dire merci.
-Ah oui, ça, c'est...
C'était...
Soupir
On avait traversé
une tempête,
ça avait été très dur
pendant plus de 10 jours,
et puis Guy Georges avait
répondu oui
à toutes les questions
posées par Alex Ursulet,
on a entendu, euh,
cette mère de victime
dire merci,
et là, c'était un moment, voilà,
de très grande humanité,
de réconciliation,
c'est-à-dire qu'on n'était
plus dans le monstre,
voilà, alors je vous dis
tout de suite, ça n'a pas duré,
parce que la colère des parties
civiles a très vite rebondi,
mais y a eu...
voilà.
-Un moment de réconciliation mais,
avant ce moment de réconciliation,
y a donc ce geste,
il se piège,
à cet instant précis,
le monde vous tombe
sur la tête,
est-ce que vous le poussez
à avouer ?
-Non, on est saisis,
mais tout va très vite
et on est ses avocats,
il nous a toujours dit
que c'était pas lui,
donc il faut réagir et là,
tout de suite, je lui demande
ce qu'il a voulu dire,
parce que, étant donné
qu'il avait déjà été condamné
pour une agression avec un couteau,
il aurait très bien pu dire :
je n'ai fait que refaire
le geste pour lequel
j'ai déjà été condamné.
Ca n'a pas été ça puisque,
en fait,
je pense qu'il était
parti ailleurs,
il était parti
dans son monde de violence
et voilà, il était plus capable
de raisonner,
ni de se défendre.
Et donc, après,
il a refusé de répondre,
il était encore plus braqué,
donc voilà, on était encore plus
dans de la culpabilité évidente.
Et c'est vrai que, après l'audience,
y a eu des suspensions,
on s'est rendu compte
avec Alex Ursulet
qu'on était au bout du chemin,
il fallait qu'il avoue.
-Et qu'est-ce qui l'accule
à la vérité ?
Une confrontation avec l'une
des victimes rescapées ?
C'est à ce moment-là ?
-Disons qu'on savait très bien
que cette victime allait
être interrogée.
S'il avait quelque chose à dire,
il fallait qu'il le dise avant.
Donc juste avant l'entrée
d'Elisabeth Ortega...
-Il a avoué.
-De votre côté,
vous vous fissurez,
en pleine audience,
vous fondez en larme.
Qu'est-ce qui vous a
bouleversée à ce point,
pour craquer ?
-Alors c'est...
-C'est rare, ça aussi,
c'est un moment d'assises rare.
-Oui,
c'est le côté sans doute
un peu ridicule de...
Mais en fait...
-Humain.
-Oui, enfin,
il y a eu une...
Il y a eu ce moment, donc,
où on voyait que Guy Georges...
basculait, avait basculé,
et la soeur d'une des victimes
est venue témoigner
et l'a vraiment supplié
de dire ce qui s'était passé.
Et cette jeune fille,
parce que c'était une jeune femme,
jeune fille, à l'époque,
était absolument poignante,
elle a eu une façon
de se tenir à la barre,
elle dansait, presque,
enfin, c'était terrible,
voilà, et là,
les 10 jours d'audience,
la tension, etc., voilà,
j'étais complètement
envahie par l'émotion.
Ce dossier Guy Georges,
c'est quand même,
c'est de la douleur,
c'est du gâchis,
y compris pour lui,
je l'inclus là-dedans,
parce qu'il aurait pu avoir
une vie différente,
il aurait dû.
-Oui, vous vous êtes identifiée
à ses victimes ?
-Non, parce qu'elles étaient
plus jeunes,
mais disons que j'étais solidaire,
je pense de... de...
de la douleur
de toutes ces familles.
Y a un moment donné,
surtout à partir du moment
où il avoue,
le combat est terminé,
donc on est envahi par...
-Par l'émotion.
-...par l'émotion
et par leur douleur.
-"Ces larmes,
c'est comme si d'un coup
"d'autres comprenaient
qu'on peut défendre
"tout en entendant
la douleur de l'autre,
"il y a contenu dans ce moment
mon métier tout entier."
-Oui.
Oui, j'ai rien à ajouter,
oui, c'est vrai.
On est du côté...
Et puis c'est vrai que,
cette cour d'assises,
on dit qu'elle est très grande,
mais on n'est pas si loin
des victimes, de leurs avocats,
donc on prend,
dans la première partie,
quand on plaidait l'acquittement,
on a pris toute leur colère,
toutes leurs agressions,
je veux dire, et c'est normal,
on est là,
on sert un peu de bouclier
à l'égard de la personne
qu'on défend, voilà,
et puis après, bon, bah,
on ressent aussi leur douleur,
on peut être les deux, voilà.
-Bien sûr.
-En fait, on n'est pas indifférents,
on n'est pas des robots.
-Vous n'êtes pas du tout
un robot,
le président décrète
une suspension d'audience,
vous retrouvez Guy Georges
dans une pièce
à l'arrière du prétoire et là,
vous avez face à vous
quelqu'un d'autre.
Pour la première fois,
vous avez peur.
-Oui, j'ai...
Il était vraiment
hors de lui.
Il était terriblement tendu,
il avait même changé,
son regard était différent,
son physique était différent,
et on avait le sentiment
qu'il était prêt à exploser.
Les gendarmes l'ont compris,
d'habitude,
ils nous laissent tranquilles
pour discuter,
et là, y en a un
qui est venu s'asseoir
juste à côté de Guy Georges
et j'ai pas pu vraiment
parler avec lui,
j'ai essayé de le détendre
mais bon, j'avais le sentiment
qu'il allait attraper le gendarme...
C'était pas identifié,
c'était aveugle,
il n'était que boule de violence.
-Mais vous êtes restée à ses côtés.
-Oh, bah quand même !
-Les psychiatres qui se sont
succédé à la barre
sont tous arrivés
à la même conclusion :
Guy Georges n'est pas fou,
il est conscient donc,
pénalement, responsable
de ses actes, bref,
il a le profil du monstre
froid indéfendable
aux yeux de nos concitoyens.
-Oui, pffh, vous savez,
je veux bien croire,
c'est tout le paradoxe
de ces analyses,
c'est-à-dire qu'on nous dit
que c'est un psychopathe,
donc c'est quand même une déviance,
une pathologie,
mais il n'est pas malade,
il est responsable.
De toute façon, Guy Georges
ne voulait absolument pas
se considérer comme quelqu'un
d'irresponsable
et aller en hôpital psychiatrique.
-Pour quelle raison ?
-Peut-être parce qu'il considérait
qu'il ne l'était pas
et qu'il était bien,
dans 90 % des cas.
En plus, c'était,
il avait passé déjà
plus de 20 ans
de sa vie en détention,
il était un prisonnier modèle,
il a une vie, euh, carcérale,
mais une vie carcérale
qui se passe bien,
sans quasiment aucun incident.
-Aujourd'hui,
il serait fondé
à demander sa libération
et pourrait théoriquement
sortir de prison.
-Théoriquement.
Il faudrait qu'il y ait
des analyses encore une fois,
des expertises psychiatriques
qui se prononcent,
qu'il y ait des magistrats
qui veuillent bien le sortir,
qu'il ait un projet de vie,
voilà, donc bon...
Je pense que tout ça,
pour l'instant, on n'y est pas.
-Quel lien avez-vous gardé
avec Guy Georges ?
-J'allais dire quasiment aucun,
et puis je pense
que tout ça,
c'est...
voilà,
c'est sa vie aujourd'hui,
il a droit,
j'allais dire,
à ce qu'on en parle pas.
Voilà, il est détenu, point.
-Vous resterez à jamais
comme l'avocate
de Guy Georges,
vous avez été immortalisée
sur grand écran en la personne
de Nathalie Baye,
mais il y a eu aussi des revers.
Un jour, lors d'un procès,
vous plaidez l'acquittement,
une des parties civiles rappelle
que vous étiez l'avocate
de Guy Georges.
Ca, c'est un coup bas ?
-Oui, enfin c'est un... oui,
c'est un coup bas,
mais ça, c'est régulier,
c'est-à-dire que,
effectivement, dès que...
Souvent, ça m'est...
on me le renvoie à la figure
pour expliquer aux magistrats
combien je suis épouvantable.
Je pense que les magistrats, voilà,
connaissent le métier d'avocat
et sont assez indifférents
à ces piques.
-Frédérique Pons,
y a-t-il quelque chose
de philosophiquement essentiel
à défendre ces hommes-là ?
C'est cette défense qui donne corps
à votre serment d'avocat ?
-Oui, François Gibault,
qui était un avocat connu,
que j'aime beaucoup,
m'a toujours dit
que les assises étaient
la vérité du métier.
Et moi, j'ai commencé
par que du droit des affaires,
donc j'ai un parcours atypique
pour venir aux assises.
Et ce qui est important,
et j'allais dire encore plus
important peut-être aujourd'hui,
c'est parce que...
On est profondément attaché
à la présomption d'innocence.
Et ce qu'il faut
envers et contre tout défendre,
c'est cette présomption
d'innocence
qui aujourd'hui ne semble
plus aussi évidente.
-"Il faut juger les gens
sur ce qu'ils ont fait
"et non sur la crainte
qu'ils nous inspirent",
disait un avocat de djihadiste.
La justice peut-elle
se prévaloir de cela
à l'heure où nous parlons ?
-Bah, elle devrait.
-Elle condamne pour punir
ou pour protéger la société ?
-L'accusation, dans les procès,
est portée par le ministère public,
qui a vocation justement à défendre
la société et à la protéger.
Il faut bien comprendre que,
on parle beaucoup
des parties civiles
qui sont dans les procès,
mais elles demandent
la réparation de leurs dommages,
le ministère public lui
défend la société
donc il va demander une peine
parce qu'il y a eu une infraction,
mais il demande aussi cette peine
pour protéger la société,
parce qu'il faut
que la peine,
elle ait un effet dissuasif
sur les autres,
sinon, ce serait l'anarchie,
si tout le monde,
si personne
ne respectait la loi.
-Les juge-t-on
pour ce qu'ils ont fait
ou pour la crainte
qu'ils nous inspirent ?
-On doit les juger
pour ce qu'ils ont fait,
il faut se garder
du procès d'intention,
mais c'est vrai que
les incriminations nouvelles
qui ont été mises en oeuvre
avec le terrorisme,
notamment les associations
de malfaiteurs
à des fins de terrorisme
ou association de malfaiteurs,
ce sont ce qu'on appelle
des infractions-balais
qui malheureusement permettent
de prendre dans leurs mailles
des personnes à qui on va dire :
bon, finalement,
vous avez pris un café avec untel,
vous auriez dû savoir
qu'il avait
l'intention de poser une bombe,
ou de faire ceci, ou de faire cela.
Et là, oui,
la démocratie est en danger,
le terrorisme n'a pas fait que
mettre notre démocratie en danger
en posant des bombes ou autre,
il la met en danger
parce que le besoin
des parlementaires de rassurer
leurs électeurs en leur donnant
plus de sécurité,
c'est leur faire plaisir
en votant des lois
en dehors des principes de la Cour
européenne des droits de l'homme
et en France, pour nous protéger,
heureusement qu'il y a la Cour
européenne des droits de l'homme.
-La parole est à la défense,
je vous laisse le mot de la fin.
-Bah, le mot de la fin,
je voudrais l'adresser
aux magistrats
parce que, dans ces temps,
on a beaucoup parlé
des difficultés avocats-magistrats,
je le déplore
parce que j'ai connu
des périodes où on pouvait
parler avec les magistrats,
faire oeuvre de justice ensemble.
Aujourd'hui,
c'est de plus en plus difficile
et non pas tant parce qu'ils ont
changé mais parce que,
effectivement, ils n'ont pas
les moyens de correctement
et j'allais dire humainement
faire leur travail
et de prendre le temps
qu'il faut pour les affaires
de nous entendre.
Quand on m'empêche
de parler à un magistrat,
on me répond qu'il travaille.
Mais je viens pas pour le déranger,
je viens
pour travailler avec lui.
Et je regrette, voilà,
que ce lien se soit délité.
-Merci, Frédérique Pons.
-Merci à vous.
-Merci.
SOUS-TITRAGE :
RED BEE MEDIA
...